we're playing this because you see my
face you're the one that's what happened
last time we recorded this game we just
start seeing brothers yeah pretty much
yep alright new level cool fun country
on yeah where do you want to go I can
show the breath whoa what the [ __ ] am I
whoa you're like the The Rocketeer I can
fly man yeah yeah
oh yeah I'll do tip no way I died
careful and say speedrun the game
Jesus Christ give the safe word is
banana oh okay
Britney whip this trunk into shape
Brants characters awesome he's like
never ever yet yeah okay oh no Josh did
it he's Oh bloated him I purchased over
the one bro are you stolen my bullet oh
yeah that's awesome doing it fight me
Did you touch it you can't that's my ex
position Oh mr. dildo machine they're
not American major US destroyer Chinese
Chinese crappy dildos yeah
America knows brahbrah
really